هل بادر احمد سعد للصلح مع طريقته تاثر
ماجد الكدواني بمفاجاه صاحبه السعاده وعرض
خاص لفيلم تشيلو اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
رايها كلي كله حكمه صوتك
تفعل متابعون منصات التواصل في مصر
والعالم العربي على نطاق واسع مع تاثر
الفنان المصري ماجد الكدواني باداء ابنته
ساندرا باغنيه في مفاجاه اعدتها له
الفنانه المصريه اسعاد يونس خلال
استضافتها له في برنامج صاحبه السعاده
الاسبوع الماضي في حلقتين دافئتين اضاءت
من خلالهما على ابرز محطات الكدواني منذ
انطلاقته
احساسي فيك وبعد اعلان مصممه الازياء
المصريه علياء بسيوني انفصالها عن الفنان
احمد سعد برغبه منه بحسب ما كشفت مؤخرا
نشر صاحب اغنيه سيرينا يا دنيا فيديو تبدو
فيه علياء في غايه التفاعل مع ادائه في
احدى حفلاته ما اعتبره متابعون بادره صلح
تجاهها كما يظهر في الفيديو ايضا ابنه
احمد من زواجه الاول وكان احمد سعد قد
احيا حفلا جماهريا مع روبي بعد نجاح الديو
الذي جمع بينهما مؤخرا
[موسيقى]
ومن مصر الى السعوديه حيث اقيم في الرياض
وسط اجوائه من بابخه العرض الخاص لفيلم
تشيلو من قصه وسيناريو تركي ال الشيخ
واخراج دارين بوسمان بحضور صناع ونجوم
الفيلم من السعوديه الكويت سوريا انجلترا
وامريكا وذلك تمهيد الانطلاقه عروضه قريبا
في صلاه السينما وتدور احداث الفيلم في
اطار من الغموض والرعب حيث يقوم عازف
تشيلو ويؤدي دوره الفنان السوري سامر
اسماعيل بعزف مقطوعه موسيقيه ملعونه تقلب
مسار حياته الهادئ راسا على عقب وتهدد
حياته وحياه اسرته كما يضم الفيلم على
قائمه اطفاله الفنان السوري القدير غسام
مسعود وسيتحدث الفنانه السوريان في الفيلم
باللهجه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
واخيرا تفعل محبو النجم السينمائيه
المصريه نجلاء فتحي التي تجاوزت السبعين
من عمرها مع صوره متداوله لاحدث ظهور لها
بعد غياب طويل ومن الصور التي حققت تفاعلا
واسعا عبر المنصات التواصل في العالم
العربي صور حفل زفاف النجم الجزائري ينادي
اهلي جده السعوديه رياض محرز على عارضه
الازياء البريطانيه تايلور وورد والذي
اقيم في لندن مؤخرا